femicides in Latin America in 2018 let's
take a look at those figures show that
in that year Brazil has the highest
number of femicides at over 1200 it's
followed by Mexico Argentina and
Honduras but if you look at the rate of
killings per hundred thousand women you
see the crisis is worst in El Salvador
with a rate of 6.8 thats followed by
Honduras and Bolivia
now seven-year old Mexican we're looking
now at a seven-year old Mexican murder
victim the murder of a seven year old
Fatima in Mexico last month further
spurred outrage ahead of strikes and
protests organized in Latin America
countries for women's day from this to
this not the usual scenes of an
International Women's Day March Chile's
capital of Santiago witnessed a
polarizing transformation in a few short
hours
it comes as women across Latin America
gathered to be heard triggered by
growing outrage they argue I'm here
because I already knew that many women
were coming we are supposed to be here
to celebrate the International Women's
Day but rather we are here to protest
fighting for equality so they don't kill
us so they don't rape us levels of
violence against women in Latin America
are among the highest in the world
[Applause]
in Mexico where more than 10 women are
killed on average everyday protesters
made their mark on the Capitol other
areas of Mexico City also saw violent
clashes with protesters confronting
police anti-abortion activists and men
[Applause]
the fact that we have this strength the
support that we can hug and gather is
great I believe that we are in a
generation that is capable of tearing
down the patriarchy in Buenos Aires
protesters gathered to demand justice
for women killed in femicides the
country is also in the midst of a
controversial debate about legalizing
abortion the president is expected to
submit a bill to Congress in the coming
days we take the streets to give
visibility to the situation that we are
living in we are in a critical cultural
moment because of what is happening to
us as women and we are here to take up
the fight to fundamentally go out into
the streets while not all women are
fighting the same battle around the
world they've seized the day to make
their voices heard
[Applause]
and joining me in the studio now is
Claudia Lozano a sociologist and
latin-american expert from the Free
University here in Berlin good morning
good morning dr. sonner why is violence
against women a bigger problem in Latin
America than elsewhere in the world
because of the impunity violence against
women it's not a problem a new problem
in the social sciences we know about it
and it happens all over the world but
the problem in Latin America has to do
with the way the police functions the
juridical system the law system the
criminal law is that they are not
protecting women rights to leave a life
without violence but and they are not
executing the criminals that is a huge
problem that's what we call impunity and
there are another problems in Latin
America which are related to poverty
women are dependent on men for for
living their own lives and I think that
this is it meant that the mas they get
into the working market they will have
the chance to support their lives by
themselves how important is the protest
movement that we're seeing right now of
course it's International Women's Day
that brings a lot of women out on the
streets but we're seeing massive
protests in Latin America focusing on
this particular problem violence against
women femicide the women movement is a
movement that has brought private
problems into or that make them a public
problem we had the problem I told you
that the violence against women is
nothing new professional women that are
working in the juridical system that I
working in hospitals know about it
because they received the cases so what
it's happening right now is because of
the numbers we are having the magnitude
of the problem is that women are talking
about it in the media they are talking
about they are taking the streets
because they want their rights to be
they are entitled and they are not
waiting somebody to come and lead
philanthropists to them so they are
taking the power and they are
and raising their voices to show with
the people the reality of violence and
that is a reality which happens in the
family it's not just in big institutions
are on the street this is not a new
problem you've been studying it for
quite some time what steps in your
opinion need to be taken to reduce the
violence against women in Latin America
and elsewhere
well persecuting the criminals showing
that the society doesn't accept that
anymore changing the culture and that is
a big challenge of the educational
system of the formal system but also of
the states in putting prevention
programs that is something we have in
Germany it is working very well that we
take people from living in different
institutions not just coming from the
law not just in schools but also in
companies because sexual abuse is
something that happens all the time and
we know that worldwide thanks there any
two movements that women feels when they
are in the working place not protected
that their right to live life without
being abused it's something that they
have to protect themselves and they have
right a right of it dr. sonner thank you
very much for talking with us this
morning that was dr. Claudia Lozano
sociologist and Latin American expert
from Berlin's pre-university thank you